Dan Gebhardt - Give Apps Online Superpowers
by Optimizing them for Offline.
Thanks a lot.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Dan.
I'm here && today to help out this little
guy.
He is the Downasaur.
If you've looked at him on a retina display
and really closely, you may have noticed that
he's a bit sad lately.
After all these years, he's still being scuttled
on cactus thorns every time a network goes
down.
But it's not just for his sake that I'll be
talking today.
A network outage can be game over for your
apps as well.
So let's show some love to the Downasaur by
making our apps work offline and everybody
will be better off in the end.
So, a little bit about me.
As Vanessa already said some of the projects
I'm involved in - Amber, Glimmer, Orbit..js,
the co-founder of Cerebris.
Let's get started with a gentle guide to offline
web apps.
Nowadays, most discussions of offline web
apps start and end with PWS, or progressive
web apps.
The PWA initiative was pioneered by Google
a few years back with the goal of making web
apps fast and engaging.
They strive to have a user experience comparable
with native apps.
Along with shareable URLs which we love.
Now is a great time to start considering PWAs,
because service workers are on the cusp of
being supported in all evergreen browsers,
desktop and mobile.
Since reliable faster and engaging are pretty
nebulous terms.
Google has developed a checklist to make these
goals more concrete, including that the site
is served over HTTPS, pages are responsive,
look good on desktop or mobile, any size,
that app URLs load while offline - highly
relevant to this talk - that you can add your
app to the home screen, just like a native
app.
And that the first experience with that app
must be fast.
And there are other requirements.
I'm not going to go over and over single one.
And that is primarily because as the Lighthouse
Chrome extension does a really good not only
of listing those requirements but also measuring
them and providing detailed reports about
your app's compliance to that checklist, including
its performance, accessibility, and more.
There are plenty of tutorials, blog posts,
and videos out there that can guide you along
the way to building and improving your PWAs.
Like this guide from Google that uses vanilla.js,
or other guides that are framework-specific,
like this post from Matthew Beale from the
Amber core team that can help you build 100
per cent compliant PWA with Amber in about
30 minutes.
And there are plenty of other guides for Angular,
React, View, and more.
I would encourage you to work within the conventions
of your framework and CLI tooling to find
a good match for you and your app.
At the end of the process, all of this tooling
will help you develop the same basic elements
of a PWA which I will review now.
First of all, there's the app shell which
is the minimal viable HTML CSS JavaScript
required to bootstrap your app.
Service workers are a background script that
act as a proxy between your application and
its environment.
Basically proxying between the main thread
of your app and in the network layer.
Service workers must be registered by your
app.
Here's an example of a registration of a service
workers that exists at sw.js an here's the
contents of that service worker.
This is about as simple as you can get.
It defines the app shell resources, the URLs
to those resources, and tells the service
worker to cache those resources when the app
is installed, and then the service workers
can serve those resources back by proxying
fetches to them.
Here's an example of a service worker that
is listening for the fetch event, and you
can customise the code that happens inside
this listener.
This one is checking the caches to see for
whether they match - they have a match in
the request, and, if so, the cache result
is returned; if not, the network fetch proceeds.
You can also do fetch first and fall-back
to cache.
Another component of PWAs is web app manifest
which describes your app to the browser.
You should link to it from your HTML.
The contents include the name, the short name,
the description, icons that will be used on
your home screen; also, a background colour
that will be displayed before the app shell
loads so that you can provide a continuous
experience from the time that app is opened
to the time it is fully loaded.
For the Downasaur's revolutionary to-do app,
we're able to cross off all of the items,
get to 100 per cent compliance with PWA, and
the Downasaur's is happy, we've saved him
from the cactuses.
However, there's legitimately one more item
that we could add to that list: interactivity.
In other words, accepting user input to change
application state, and then syncing those
changes when you're app comes back online.
For a to do app in which you can't actually
add to dos or mark them complete, it's pretty
unsatisfying.
You know it's better than nothing but not
that much better.
So, web standards have helped us greatly so
far.
Can they help us here?
Perhaps soon, the Chrome team introduced a
new web API called background sync in 2015.
And there are implementations under way in
Firefox, Edge, and Chrome, but they are all
experimental and it may be a while before
this settles out as a stable API and becomes
something that we can rely on in your production
apps.
Lucky, we have time left, because we don't
want to end on a down note.
So, if we're going to get to that next level
of interactivity, immutability, even while
offline, we are clearly going to need some
heroics.
We are going to take the PWA to the next level
and build one that's not only resilient to
network outages but allows for full interactivity.
So we need to step back a bit to figure this
out in terms of our application's architecture.
Let's back way up, and look at the architecture
of most web apps.
On the back end, engineers have virtually
unlimited processing power and access to everything
in milliseconds.
This is power.
The Norse gods would probably love backend
engineering.
I think Loki invented microservices, in fact!
Meanwhile, on the front end, our options are
much more constrained and our job is made
much more difficult because of those constraints.
Modern front-end engineering, and I'm sure
everyone is aware, is more than adding a nice
coat of paint for forms.
We often need to manage application state,
beta records, which usually is done in a layer
I called the back end of the frond-end.
This layer can get pretty gnarly if we're
not careful.
But this is where we need to solve our offline
interactivity.
So what do we need to do to manage offline
state in this layer?
You might come up with a back-of-the-napkin
list of requirements that look something like
this.
You need to track and cue changes that happen
offline; you need to generate and assign identities
to records.
Serialise and persist all change sets and
queues so that, if the browser is closed unexpectedly,
and you don't use all your user's data, then,
when your app comes back online, you need
to sync your changes back to your server,
and, of course, that doesn't always go smoothly,
and sometimes, you will need to reconcile
any conflicts, or problems, and perhaps even
revert to an earlier state.
Now, if you're a developer and we probably
all are, or most of us are here, this probably
sounds like a feature list for a tool we use
every day.
And it was Git was one of my inspirations
when I wrote Orbit.js.
Since it stabilised in the fall and guides
were launched, we are seeing people using
it with every front-end framework.
Many of the core packages are isomorphic and
work on Node as well.
Orbit was originally written in JS but rewritten
in TypeScript, but of course the packages
are shipped with all the standard JS builds.
You can use it with either.
So, orbit use cases go beyond offline.
Orbit attempts to solve a number of problems.
Client-first development, where you're prototyping
a feature without prototyping the back end
to fulfil it.
Pluggable sources.
Orbit's very interface-based, so sources that
share interfaces can be substituted for each
other.
For instance, index DB could fall back to
local storage.
Most modern web apps involve more than one
source of data, often more than two.
If you're Wright an offline web app, at a
minimum, you have browser storage, and remote
server, and you probably have an in-memory
store, and you might even have data streaming
in from other sources like web sockets to
service an event.
And speaking of the main store, it's really
nice to work with immutable data so be able
to fork stores, make edits, and throw away
the edits or commit them back, merge them
back to the main store, but have total control
over that process.
And orbit deterministically tracks changes
to each source with the ability to undo or
redo those changes.
Because your apps work offline, they can work
optimistically, even when other online.
They don't need to be hindered by a delay
in the request-response cycle.
For some changes, you can optimistic about
their application, and then only handle failures
as they come up.
But, show a success immediately to the user.
Stepping back philosophically, orbit considers
all these sources of data that need to communicate
with each other.
And they all have different data in different
forms.
So we need to put common interfaces on them,
and we need to normalise data that flows between
them.
They also need to communicate with each other.
That's done three event.
They can be wired up in any order based on
their events.
And the event allow for some flow control.
The events are promisified and they delay
the resources of another request.
Then, through that chain of requests, then
a single - a single request may not succeed
until that whole chain is successful.
And the Git inspiration really shows in the
change tracking in which immutable operations
are stored and tracked according to an ID,
just like commits in a branch's history.
Every source is essentially has a branch with
a history, and that history of course can
grow, and that can be truncated when everything
lines up, but you can always tell the state,
the differences between different branches
or different sources, and essentially cherry-pick
between the branches or the sources, and keep
things in sync, and you know, create new forks
or discard them.
Data features strongly in this, especially
inside the memory store which uses immutable
data structures to cache the data and allows
for - which allows for cheap and fast forking.
Orbit has a lot of parts.
There's a core library, Orbit core, which
I'm not going to go into too much today, but,
essentially, it has a lot of primitives that
allow for the log, the history tracking, and
the essentially the async event co-ordination
so you could use it to think of it as an async
Redux almost.
But at the data layer, it gets more concrete.
This is where some opinions are layered on
top of orbit actually making it useful in
applications.
So there is a notion of a schema shared amongst
sources, and that schema shares models, relationships,
and keys.
Every single source in orbit data has a schema,
a log of transforms that have been applied
to it, and a couple of cues that can cue up
async requests and sync events.
Then there are optional interfaces.
These are dependent upon the capabilities
of a particular source, so, only some source
- you can only becomingly query some sources.
Almost all sources can sync with each other.
The interfaces that you would interact with
most are the update - updatable interface
and the queryable interface.
The updatable interface basically supports
a single-method update which takes a transform,
and that transform has an ID, and it can be
assigned a label, so you can actually, you
know, put - display that label if it is cued
up.
You can display it in your UI.
You could say what went wrong, so you can
attach some metadata to this transform.
Transform consists of an array of operations.
Those operations might be in this case, they're
adding a planet - the planet Jupiter, or the
moon Io, and then Io to Jupiter in the moon's
relationship.
And that set of operations can be compounded
into a single transplant.
That's not very friendly to write, so there
is a builder interface to make that easier
to construct.
Queryable sources allow for query sources
to be passed to a query method, and, again,
these can be labelled.
This is the raw form of a query expression,
and this is the builder form.
We were requesting all the planets and sort
them by name.
Something to focus on here is that all the
sources that say implement the queryable interface
in your application are able to understand
the same query expressions.
And so you can make a query against the memory
store in the same way you can make a query
against your back-end remote store, or your
in-memory store.
So they speak a common language, and they
have a common understanding about the normalised
data that they are working with.
To get them all to talk to each other, that's
where the co-ordinator comes in.
The co-ordinator works with sources and applies
strategies to those sources.
For instance, this is adding a strategy to
sync everything that happens, that happens
to the store to the back-up source which might
be an index DB source.
This is an example of optimistic updating
where a request strategy is added to that
before the store is updated, we're going to
push that same, that update to the remote
source.
If we had added a blocking true to that, it
would turn into a pessimistic update, because,
essentially, this is now saying that the store
won't be updated until the remote's push event
has completed successfully.
So, depending upon whether you want to be
optimistic or pessimistic, you can customise
your strategies, and you can write your own
completely custom strategies that have their
own JavaScript logic here, but there are just
some that are provided for convenience.
Of course, things do go wrong, especially
it would be irresponsible not to have some
failure handling in offline scenarios, or
optimistic updating, and so, you might need
to write a strategy that responds to a failure
event, and takes an action, like this here
is responding to a network error on the remote
source, and it will retry the queue of actions
every five seconds.
In this scenario, we are communicating back
to the user a failure based upon the label
that's put on in update, and then we are rolling
back the transform to - we're rolling back
the store state just before that transform
was applied.
Then we are skipping events on the remote
source, so it's basically a reset.
We're throwing up our hands.
It could be - we could be a lot more sophisticated
about this and do some reconciliation.
We're obviously not going to do the same thing
as a Git interactive rebase with our users
involved in choosing which changes to accept,
but we can put a really nice interface on
a similar process, or we can just have some
hard-coded priorities for which changes succeed
in which cases.
Something like this might be a fallback when
you've gone through all your custom handling.
Finally, this is an example of pulling all
of the records out of browser storage source,
the back named back-up there, and then sinking
those with the store before the co-ordinator
is activated.
It activates all of the strategies so that
orbits co-ordinator starts to watch everything
and keep it all in sync.
So getting back to PWAs, and applying Orbit
to keep them interactive.
What does that look like?
What is our strategy here?
The Orbit PWA still needs a service worker.
It needs to handle caching and fetching of
the app shell resources, but it does not typically
intercept API fetches because those can be
cued of a main thread or a worker thread.
They don't need to be proxied in the service
worker.
They might have sources like a store, a back-up
source, which probably would be index DB,
and a remote, or a remote source, maybe a
JSON API source, or you might want to add
a real time source like sockets, or service
an event.
And then the process for booth an orbit PWA,
the app shell fetched from the service worker
went offline, the stores populated with data
from back-up, like the example I showed earlier,
and then the co-ordinators activated, and
all the strategies are activated along with
it, so orbit can keep monitoring things.
Strategy might be something like this.
Everything that - every change to the store
is synced to back-up; every change that happens,
that is observed on the remote source, syncs
to the store; every time the store is queried,
a request is made to the remote source, and
the same with updates.
So all of this allows us to finally check
off that last item on our to-do list.
And it also allows us to add a whole bunch
of more items, a whole bunch of more capabilities
for our app, whether it is offline, or online.
And I think the Downasaur is happy.
If you're interested in orbit, the guides
are on the orbit.js.com.
I'm working to fully flesh out the site.
I hope it will get you started, and please
feel free to follow orbit on Twitter if you're
interested.
Thanks very much.
[Applause].